avec cette signature villepreux devient
la première ville des yvelines à
s'engager officiellement contre les
perturbateurs endocriniens
ces substances chimiques qui comme leurs
noms l'indiquent perturbe notre système
hormonal sont partout alimentation
cosmétiques et produits du quotidien à
villepreux
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 la
restauration pour les enfants et les
seniors et bio en 2015 la commune avait
également éliminé les produits
phytosanitaires pour l'entretien des
espaces verts
on a une politique extrêmement clair
c'est inclus réintégrer l'environnement
la démarche environnementale dans
chacune de nos décisions c'est ce que
nous avions fait et la bonne surprise
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
eh ben on a pu signer cette charte ça
montre vraiment l'engagement de
villepreux des habitants et de l'équipe
municipale pour l'environnement cette
charte a été mise en place par
l'association réseau environnement santé
en france près de 200 communes l'ont
signée y compris la région ile de france
objectif réduire l'exposition de la
population aux perturbateurs
endocriniens et l'enjeu des
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est que
c'est des sons des expositions
de courte durée pendant une période
sensible de la grossesse ou la petite
enfance qui va induire des impacts
sanitaires chez l'enfant
mais chez le futur adulte et même jeu
les descendants la charte comprend
également un volet achats responsables
les citoyens doivent aussi être informés
tous les ans de l'avancement des
engagements pris par la commune